yeah you know I don't really dress like
this I just felt like since we're doing
some baller [ __ ] I put that velvet on
[Music]
burgers are food for the people the
cheaper the quicker the more accessible
the better but these days the smoked
beef blends and luxury toppings are
driving prices through the roof today
I'm teaming up with food TV legend Adam
Richman to eat our way through baller
burger history and to figure out what
upgrades are worth it and which are for
the suckers so here's my thing that I've
noticed a lot of times when they
reinterpret any kind of comfort food
dish fries to Sunday's to whatever with
like fancy ingredients or iron
ingredients it either works or alienates
people like burgers were Pro Terry you
know we all are good eaters but then
does this wave of the fancy burger and
the custom blends and the cave age crew
years yeah like that you actually have a
restaurant I just have an appetizer
what do you think drives up the cost of
forty seven dollar burger it's all about
like what we perceive is baller free
oceans of dollar above we're talking
about Martin potato that's like sixteen
cents a bun now we're talking to charge
three to three times more to make it
like that one dollar bun is actually
three dollars sir consumer right without
even meat you're already at three bucks
you're at like you're at you're at an
in-and-out cheeseburger right right just
for the bun respect right and then
you're like okay let's get beef blends a
short rib brisket ribeye
so let's say we've got two ounces of
each turn as a six ounce burger let's
say $16 a pound to make it easy math
right so now you're talking about a six
dollar burger patty - no that's again an
18 now it's 18 customer costomer so you
got three dollar bun
you got an $18 patty now we're talking
about cave-ins Grier I might not be like
out the gates a big fan of all this
stuff but sometimes when you do see
fancy ingredients are kind of like know
what my treat myself you know I mean
like Joseph caviar on my program I like
burgers I feel like we're sure
today I've been talking about them are
you ready to begin the bougie burger
Bonanza I'm a ride with you brah alright
eNOS so these are the big baller burgers
between three of them we're going an
increasing price culminating with a
3-digit Burke hey the champ is here what
inspired this burg oh this is the bash
burger this is a creation that I was
inspired by some local diners it's my
version of a bacon onion cheeseburger oh
we went with a caramelized onion and
bacon jam secret sauce shaved pickles
American cheese on a big Marty
sesame-seed bun' ya notice notice the
two big fat on your rings on top it's
really dude
okay real fans you're still that's a big
that's a pretty good-looking burger I
tell you so a little trick that we do a
little trick of the trade if you will I
was in a West Coast burger chain okay
that we're all very familiar with a
little in and out and I remember I went
there for a little R and D they do a
little swipe of mustard when it's on
there yeah right on the burger and put
it down do it
yo that's near and dear to my heart man
just take a rip of that oh yeah it's
[ __ ] good burger man one day I'm
gonna like to enjoy a bachelor go so
amazing out of man I'm blown away dude
so good
it's the ultimate chef street cred
burger it hides its pedigree very well
definitely it's perfectly constructed
what do you think man is this a success
I love the highbrow lowbrow I think
that's that's the only way to make it
work you got a potato roll with the
custom beat but you got bacon jam and
Heinz ketchup and I'm damned if Eddie
Heinz matches it deserves to be on a
plate next to fries Mayo ketchup it's
it's that burger again it's that burger
it's amazing so this is the Minetta
tavern Black Label burger going up
another bracket right right
quickly dissecting at me you can you can
tell that the core of this burger yep
you can smell it's the dry aged steak
alright funkiness being from Los Angeles
and being like a a guy from the outside
looking in right like this is that that
burger is that mystique the Minetta
burger it was almost like do you have
your serious foodie passport stamp
let's stop talking let's let's try this
bad boy oh it's perfectly tough well
used to taste that age that was just
about to say that I don't know if I've
had a burger that tastes as much like a
steak dinner as this like I've worked in
dry-aged room so I'm dry aged steak
smell like I feel like I'm in a giant
out any a burger it's so wild yeah
the blend is brisket short rib and rib
eye right all aged when the Minetta
tavern burger came out when they had
their signature blend it was crazy
because everybody wanted to corner the
market got some that no one else
terrified err it's it's almost like the
easy of meat they cook it in HD fat and
plus because they have that connection
with Balthasar and they're the best
boulangerie is in the city that created
this bond that I thought ice brioche as
well and then I read about it that it
has like a slightly higher buttery
content like a croissant you can see the
layers when they let it rest they put
the onions right in that puddle of beef
fat it's so weird that I knows it's so
much about the burger it's kind of like
you go to someone after like swiping
right and it's like I know so much about
you but we've never met before it is so
creepy off bat you know like the first
burger we had was like something that
you want to party with right it's like
it's a burger I wanted to tell my
friends about like oh yeah you got to
have this here share here's a bite this
one's kind of like nothin then like no
this is me like don't touch this yo man
this is the most baller burger I've ever
even looked at I don't know if I've ever
had there's many opulent ingredients on
any single Josaphat I'm gonna tell you
it's $295 let me tell you what's in this
bad boy
so this Burger has Japanese Wagyu beef
stuffed with ten herb white truffle
butter seasoned with smoked sea salt
topped with the Balinese cheddar aged 18
months in England
shave black truffle a fried quail egg
white truffle butter buttered on to this
Campania roll topped with a Bellini
topped with creme fraiche topped with
caviar and then it's got a
diamond-encrusted toothpick and gold
dust my G this is its bougie I don't
really my teeth like cristão I don't
even know if I want to put ketchup on it
I hope I don't feel like you don't need
that I'm sweating need is not a Minion's
man I'm not yeah my mouth this
conference is a little yeah I know
they're ever gonna get back at a slash
in a little bit okay
it's wrist it's like holding my mouth to
me it's like why if you're going to
spend the national debt I'm gonna stuff
inside the burger would you have stuff
that not only takes moisture out of your
mouth right takes moisture out of the
burger and then competes it's like I
can't eat all this I'm a purist my con
is like I don't need all that stuff I I
like it individually I like the
ingredients but I just like a brother I
think sometimes when it gets so fancy it
gets a little bit inaccessible and so
that's why sometimes I can appreciate
the culinary merit but is it gonna eat
that burger did you may not gravitate
towards it it may not be your fasting
but that's not what they do they set out
to be yeah they set out to be the most
expensive most elite from top to bottom
full experience of a burger would you
ever order it would I ever order this
burger yup I probably wouldn't as a
simple kid from East LA I'm gonna choose
a $33.00 burger and maybe buy a pair of
sneakers you know I mean I must say I'm
gonna save the money I'm gonna spend it
but I'll put it on something else
[Music]
unlimited funds we've had three of the
best be the most gourmet which of the
three do you think you might go back to
you may go back to all three cash out
all my Bitcoin we ballin I'm gonna go
with my point Josh Capone's burger man
yeah I mean it's it's a good burger yeah
it transcends gourmet it's a good bird
Josh's burger to me hits that burger
note that juicy smoky salty kind of
thing I admit I'm friends with Josh and
I don't I'm not gonna want to seem like
I'm showing him any kind of favoritism
I'm else have to be honest in terms of
style construction composition I
preferred the bachelor in terms of where
I go through my mind by burger well I've
had the minutes having burger but biting
into that Josh Capone burger man coming
off guard I almost like had to take a
step back I'm like yo this is a burger
mansburg
yes and I think yeah that's that's what
it is that's what's up that's right yeah
that's what this show is about
[Music]
time to busy picking the teeth we'll go
down to this